qui diable pensez-vous que vous êtes
qui était génial
aller costume
oh qu'est-ce qu'il dit bienvenue dans le
[ __ ] de criard dans la galaxie
sacré tu n'as pas utilisé de [ __ ]
oh attention oh j'ai essayé de m'habiller
le destin de l'univers réside dans ton
épaule  maintenant, quoi que vous fassiez, n'appuyez pas là-dessus,
mais la bombe a explosé
immédiatement et nous serons tous morts
maintenant, répétez ce que je viens de dire
Congrès, non, c'est le bouton pour
eux, tuez tout le monde, essayez à nouveau
-huh No
show Tommy tient
[Musique]
oh vous voyez, est-ce
que quelqu'un a de la bande là-bas
J'aurais mis du papier avec un bureau
mais personne n'a rien pas une seule
personne n'a de bande vous avez une bombe atomique
dans votre sac si quelqu'un est  va faire
tuer des bébés je dois le faire pour vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est un très mauvais signe
ah
vous pouvez toucher quelqu'un et ressentir ses
sentiments oui ouais ouais ouais je suppose ouais
je ressens un amour général désintéressé pour à
peu près ça  Je ne sais pas
hahaha donc tout le monde est au plus profond
mec secret le plus sombre allez tu exagères
un peu
tu dois être si gentil hahahahaha juste
peut-être que le chrétien te prépare